it feels that way i mean it really does
feel as though
any common bonds that we once shared are
basically disintegrating
and that you're being pressured into
mimicking the belief that all those
bonds are gone
so even if you believe that the bonds
aren't really frayed and that really we
should have some stuff in common
if you say that out loud you're part of
the system you're part of the white
supremacist system
and this is it's such dangerous stuff
and as we're sitting here
very in the last few hours there was a
there was a
sort of graphic that came out from the
national museum of african american
history and culture which is a
smithsonian institute
taxpayer-funded institution by the
government funded by the government
uh and it was all about whiteness and
the evil's whiteness and among the evils
of whiteness things that we've all
integrated into our lives because
of the prevailing system of white
supremacy where things like hard work
individualism justice time management
delayed gratification science i'm not
kidding this is all in the document
these are all these are all things that
are listed
as elements of white supremacy that must
be rejected in order to move forward
into a better
more progressive world
[Music]
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report quick reminder everybody to
subscribe to our youtube channel and
click that notification bell especially
especially on a day like today when i
have a guest
so dangerous that we're going to get in
a lot of trouble you understand
the man sitting across from me that's
right it is ben shapiro
author of the new book how to destroy
america
in three easy steps here we go again my
friend
i know just get ready for it you get you
get worse than i do i mean
honestly i'm okay my people will be fine
you're the one who pays
the price do i get it worse than you i'm
not sure you have a very
dedicated group of people at media
matters who
sit and wait for you to nod
or to move in a way that they can imply
is white supremacist i have a i have a
bunch of anonymous anime genderless
trolls
that's that that's right these are
really that's fair i have a full
employment program going over media
matters i know we have at least one
maybe two people who are on us basically
full-time at daily wire so that's
that's exciting i'm glad that we can
create jobs in all sectors of the
economy
we are creating jobs i think the obvious
way to start this interview because i
want to focus on your book but i you
know of course we have to talk about
some of the things i don't know if
you've heard there's a pandemic and then
riots have you
i missed all of this yeah i've been out
of
you're a busy guy um but you know i
titled my book don't burn this book and
then
basically the day the book came out
every store that
had the book was on fire
but he didn't say don't burn the store
to be fair i didn't say don't burn the
store that's
you know how's the book now your book is
called how to destroy america in three
easy steps
it was about how to burn your book yeah
that's that's the the basic gist of it
but of all times america does seem like
it's being destroyed right now and
that's what you titled the book and i
know a little something about writing
you finish this book when
how long december january okay so
actually not that no
it was this is a quick write so what
happened is that i had gone to israel
for the jewish holidays i came back
and i just looked around the country and
i thought something is really really
deeply wrong i mean even more wrong than
it has been
in prior iterations and it's been wrong
for a while i mean there have been
things that have been going wrong which
is why i wrote the previous book right
side of history which was the country's
kind of falling apart
what do we do what common values do we
hold and then i thought well we really
need
sort of a nation-specific book about
what we're supposed to be sharing
because obviously
there's this widespread perception that
we share nothing right the only thing
that we share is an oppressive evil
terrible bigoted system
and so i come back from israel i called
up my publisher
i have a two-book deal with my publisher
and my publisher i actually had another
book that was slated to come out
uh probably the beginning of next year
and i said i want to rush a book out
before the election
i want it to be called how to destroy
america in three easy steps and i'm
gonna write it in the next six weeks
and they were like do you write as i
guess as you talk i do i i thank god i
write incredibly i used
i was actually uh little known ben
shapiro facts i used to uh
many there are many of them but one of
the one of the least well known as i was
a ghost writer for many prominent
figures for probably
a decade that's how i supplemented my
income so i have something like seven or
eight new york times bestsellers that
are not under my own
name i was the quick right specialist
publishers would come to me there would
be some prominent figure
who you know had three weeks to go until
deadline and they'd be like okay well
you've got
one sentence what do we do and so they
turned me over the book and i'd write an
entire book in a month so that those
can i get you to write a couple of their
names on the back of that paper i'll
tell you later
i'll tell you later if not in violation
my ndas guys
in any case uh it was written at white
heat uh and it was
very easy to write because the structure
of the book is
is very obvious i mean the basic idea if
we don't go that far yet i want to okay
we'll get to it in a second i wrote down
all six chapters because i want to talk
strongly all right
i think the way you broke it down
actually is super interesting
um but before we do full book stuff
let's just talk about
the world as it is at the moment for
just a little bit do you believe on the
show
oh you can curse your brains out but but
what do you mean you're you're a you
don't curse
i know but i do if you promise me you'll
believe but then i'll curse oh i
i yes my people will bleep it yeah we're
sort of
i've been waiting for that for a long
time shapiro because i've heard you say
[ __ ] off my guys don't have to bleep my
[ __ ] they can bleep your face yeah
that's what you say [ __ ] privately and
then you
you put your little as you know as you
know there is a bit of a gap between
public persona and
in private curse of blue streak because
you know so that's not that's not a
great shock but yes
okay so yeah let's let's just do it for
a little bit uh are we [ __ ] like what
the hell is going
on here right now um it feels that way i
mean it really does feel as though
any common bonds that we once shared are
basically disintegrating
and that you're being pressured into
mimicking the belief that all those
bonds are gone
so even if you believe that the bonds
aren't really afraid and that really we
should have some stuff in common
if you say that out loud you're part of
the system you're part of the white
supremacist system
uh and this is it's such dangerous stuff
and as we're sitting here
very in the last few hours there was a
there was a
sort of graphic that came out from the
national museum of african american
history and culture which is a
smithsonian institute
taxpayer-funded institution by the
government funded by the government
uh and it was all about whiteness and
the evil's whiteness and among the evils
of whiteness things that we've all
integrated into our lives because of the
prevailing system of white supremacy
where things like hard work
individualism justice time management
delayed gratification science i'm not
kidding this is all in the document
these are all these are all things that
are listed
as elements of white supremacy that must
be rejected in order to move forward
into a better
more progressive world and so all the
things that you would think like yeah i
feel like we should all have this in
common like you know science
this one this one we should have in
common there's a whole movement say no
no all of these things are outgrowths of
an evil system
and that in turn is a the result of
an absolutely despicable redefinition of
the term
racism for what it used to mean in for
virtually all of human history but
certainly since the 1960s
to what it means now so in the 1960s
racism was what we all think of racism
as
believing in the inferiority or
superiority of a particular racial group
right very easy definition you can spot
it wherever you see it right
it's not not hard it's very easily
applied definition and then there's been
an attempt in the last several years to
redefine racism to mean
any system that results in racial
inequality
is itself racist and so if you are not
seeking the destruction of that system
you are complicit in racism and in order
to be anti-racism you have to seek to
destroy that system well
every system in human history has
resulted in inequality of some sort or
another because human beings
have different capacities we make
different choices if you literally you
tell me we're not
all exactly the same we don't have all
the exact same thoughts and gifts and
skills you're telling me
stop being racist stop it stop it so
it's slightly different
abram kenzie specifically writes this
right and how to be an anti-racist he
says literally any system
that generates racial inequality is a
racist system
and so therefore it's not like you're a
bad person because you're a racist
you're just a product of the system or
you're upholding the system and in order
for us to fight that racism we have to
fight
the system itself and so anything that
is part of that system anything and
everything that is of that system
is tainted by racism and must be ripped
down
completely and if you are complicit in
the system by by doing things like hard
work and individualism you're an
assimilationist right this is what abram
kennedy says and how to be an
anti-racist and robin d'angelo sort of
mirrors this
and you're saying yourself wait a second
aren't you closing in an awful lot of
doors
to black americans and minority
americans like the pathways to success
in a free system are things like hard
work individual effort
you know thinking ahead delayed
gratification like this is not unique to
capitalism or the evil american system
or anything right but also what are you
saying about
it's insane black mean david duke could
write this [ __ ] right i mean he really
could i mean david duke could write the
idea that whiteness
is about hard work and individual
initiative
and religious adherence and family
structure right that's crap david duke
would write yeah but the anti-racists
are writing the exact same crowd and
they're saying yeah but all those things
are bad right and if we just got rid of
our adherence to these systems well then
we wouldn't really have to have
standards that we hold people to and
then equality
would be the result i mean that's
insanely dangerous stuff but because the
charge of racism is the most
is the most highly charged charge you
can make against somebody it's the worst
thing you can call somebody in america
and for good reason because that is an
awful thing to be right it's an awful
thing to say about somebody it's an
awful thing to be
because that is such a highly loaded
term
it's so easy to cuddle people into line
all you have to do is just acquiesce
all you have to do is be the person who
cheers on the guillotines as the
guillotines chop off heads
and we'll leave you alone now we're not
going to say that you're left alone
forever right
this only holds true until the time for
the next guillotine um
but you're coming but i really feel like
in this situation it's very much like
the
the action movie where the bad guy comes
to the good guy and he's got some
blackmail to hold over his head and the
good guy says well how do i know you
won't use it and the bad guy goes
you don't yeah right that that's that's
the anti-racist movement yeah
they figure that they can call you a
racist and they will hold that over your
head
until you acquiesce in all the things
and if you don't acquiesce in this one
little thing
then you will be ruined and you will be
destroyed and you will be targeted as
part of the opposition if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell